[موسيقى]
اسم moe غير معروف جيدًا
لأنه لم ينجح في جولة pga التي نعيشها
في هذه الثقافة التي نحتفل فيها
بالمشاهير
وأولئك الذين حققوا ذلك على
أعلى مستوى
لم يفعلوا ذلك  لم يفز
في جولة pga ،
لقد كان أسطورة في كندا
والأشخاص الذين سمعوا عنها سمعوا عن
اسمه انتشر في جميع أنحاء العالم
حتى تصبح معروفًا حقًا يجب
أن تكون معروفًا من قبل
الجماهير وهذا من خلال الشعبية  الثقافة حول
وسائط الرياضيات وهذا النوع من الأشياء
، لذا فإن moe هو أكثر من بطل عبادة
يمكنك قراءته
في مقال المجلة وملخص الجولف
هنا وهناك وهكذا
في الكتب وهذا النوع من الأشياء
ولهذا السبب حقًا  لم يكن مو
معروفًا جيدًا ،
ولا أعتقد أنني رأيت أي شخص يفعل
ما يمكن أن يفعله كرة الجولف
بقدر اتساق الرحلة ،
والنوافذ التي كان سيضرب كرة الجولف فيها
و  بهذه البساطة
[موسيقى]
كانت هناك أيضًا حادثة في الثانية
في العام الذي تحدث فيه
لاعبان في الجولة إلى
مو في غرفة خلع الملابس وقال إنه
يجب عليك التوقف عن العبث ،
خذ القطة وتوقف مع
كل هذا النوع من الأشياء
وشعر بالإهانة
وغادر الجولة التي كان فيها  تنافس أو
بطولة تركها
قال إنها كانت وهذا أدى إلى
مدى الحياة من
الشعور بأنهم لا يحبونه
وهو وإذا كان لدى مو إحساس أن أه الناس
لديهم منتدى أو أنهم كانوا
هنا  وكان هنا
أو شعرت بأنك تعرضت للإهانة من قبله ،
كان سيكتب لك فرقًا كبيرًا
بين ما إذا
كنت في دائرته الداخلية وإذا
لم تكن كذلك ،
وإذا كنت ستذهب إليه في
الشارع وهو  قد
لا أتحدث معك حتى وتذهب بعيدًا
أو يمكنك أن تقول شيئًا لي ،
فسيبدو وقحًا للغاية ، لذا إذا كنت في
تلك الدائرة الداخلية عندما كنت ألعب الجولف
معه ، فقد اعتقدت أنه كان
رائعًا للعب الجولف  مع أنه كان
ودودًا وممتعًا
للغاية وسيكمل لقطاتك وهو
ها  عندما تلعب
، أعني أنه كان مثل صديقك تمامًا